Is it best to go through menopause without taking any take it all just let it do its course?
No, if so when you go through menopause, you're overly shut down and
Gradually you produce less and less progesterone and estrogen
Now
Women that go through menopause and go yeah, I didn't really have any menopause symptoms
You know I was grand glad I didn't have my period anymore blah blah blah. I didn't know I kind of sailed through it. They have really healthy
um
Adrenal glands so your adrenal glands do make some estrogen progesterone
um and
they're supposed to kind of
Make up the difference not at all the same amount but they will make up the difference so you kind of go through menopause in a nice
gradual way as your ovaries start to degenerate
um
People that have serious problems with menopause. We're not talking about people on
Estrogen-lowering medication. We're talking about just menopause
Um, when your ovaries are shutting down and they have serious
um
hot flashes and symptoms
You really want to support
the adrenal glands
so
especially if you have history uh breast cancer
You don't want to go and give
soy
bison flavonoid
Like we talked about with jettison or something like that
um if you have a history of breast cancer if you don't have any history of cancer
That's what I would use but if you do have a history of cancer, I would only use adaptogens
So you do things that will support a adrenal function but you might not need to so let's say you know
You particularly are at a lot of supplements that say you need to do that
But supporting a adrenal function is what you would do if you had symptoms